j'aime faire l'amour avec des gants
[Musique]
c'est tout un style assurément
ces colonnes moi pas vraiment
le plaisir
si important
j'aime faire l'amour avec les corps
et gants de pau évidemment
sur la peau j'en fais le serment
frémir tous mes amants
cette altitude
ce que je rajoute
à tout ce que je fais en plus dépenses
c'est un petit truc
ce que je rajoute à tout ce que je fais
tout ce qui t'entoure
j'aime faire l'amour
non après les enterrements les gants
violet très excitant
et les chagrins dure moins longtemps
j'aime bien mon
mega
et je veux dire
[Musique]
élégamment
pissas
tous les remontant
vous réveille des sentiments
c'est un titre
plus que je rajoute à tout ce que je
fais en plus
tu te vois
c'était
ans puisque je rajoute à tout ce que je
fais plus
[Musique]
parlé d'un péché mortel qui traîne sa
vie à tire d'aile pour ce jeune homme de
bonne famille
qui aime un petit peu trop le fil
pourtant si j'étais lui je ferai
attention tout même pas tous les jours
qu elle dit je t'aime
la petite marine
pourtant si je tenais je ferai attention
tout de même
passer sa vie sans acheter
c'est pas une vie sans manier
c'est vrai je suis sans péché mortel
sans doute pour lui que je suis qu'il ne
fallait pas rencontre
qu'il n'aurait pas dû regarder
vous parlez d'un péché mortel moi qui
croyais that revenir pour ce jeune homme
de bonne famille
qui aime un petit peu trop les filles
si j'étais
fera attention tout malaise
pas tous les jours qu elle dit
la petite marie
m
pourtant si j'étais lui je ferai
attention to me
ah c'est sa vie sans un je t'aime
c'est pas une vie ouais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu